hello
slightly early
good morning good morning
good morning
i think we're live
doo doo doo
[Music]
hello
what is up i don't know what to write
here
hey man
what's up sub zero
thanks for becoming a member by the way
i saw you did that when i was offline so
thank you man
thank you dude
um
hear from rocket league anybody else
i also play eldon right what's up k
i haven't heard anything about rocket
league in a long time man
what's up kyle ludwig
augusto
hey you have a great day liz thank you
another dude called kyle in here
there are many kyles in the world
many
think
let's see
sekiro
this is our boy here
where were we
i need to stream more
oh yeah
we need to beat this guy i was trying to
get footage of god of god of roy got
afraid
we gotta try again though
let me go back up here real quick
we gotta be gotta fro
won't watch a lot because i don't want
to be spoiled more than i have been
that's fine man
watch to your heart's content or don't
at all
i've 100 mastered this on ps5
it was a goddamn test of insanity and
patience i'm trying it myself
it's uh it's a lot
we'll see how it goes though why am i
here
i want to be
here
i'm stupid
i gotta go to sleep
okay well good night
it's nine in the morning for me
i'm sure it's a different time for most
people
oh it's funny what's up man
piggy yo yo
yo yo
didn't i set the timer for nine o'clock
kyle
i think i did or did i set it for 9 30.
i don't remember
what's up mission
[Music]
is
ice rind hatchet
that's probably the
poor frost stomp right
moonville katana better they're both
really good
that's like pvp so
that's kind of up to you
[Music]
the most confusing
random ass boss in the game
apparently this is not godric
ah
it's his lame brother
now
i've heard brother cousin
dad grandpa
i've heard everything about this guy
i'm getting hit a lot
man swing bro
okay
we gotta wake up baby
[Music]
i hear reduce reused asset as well
there we go
hi pascal
good morning
there's that bleed
there's that
there's that
easy peasy
it's not his brother he didn't cut off
his arm
i don't think even if he did that would
make him his brother
people tell me a lot of stuff about this
guy but i don't know where they get the
information from
they're like yeah it's his cousin i'm
like
how do you know that
then they're like i don't know
then i'm just like sick you get a lot of
runes for that my god
hello luke
welcome
brother from a different mother why do
they look exactly the same
exactly the same
it's coincidence because i used this
account
to uh to get the footage for the last
video but i didn't kill him
because i wanted to kill him on stream
for you guys
but i didn't
so i like got some footage of him and
then just like left the fight
plastic surgery i wonder why they want
to look
exactly the same then you know
i got no idea bro okay what's this
oh we got to kill this guy huh
there's a um
there's a cave over here too that we
could look at
i'm not increasing the bitrate that
would be on you sir
my bit rates as high as it can go
increase your internet
bang bang
what the hell
oh blood blade
nice
identity theft
maybe
they're obviously related but isn't
known father brother sister could be
anything really i mean yeah i would
assume they're related
but we don't know exactly how and then
the most confusing thing is why do they
look exactly the same
you come here
is that a giant the hell
i'll probably lock onto you
there we go
the hell these guys doing
summoning code
i should whoa okay
you were chained to something earlier
oh he's chained to a tree what the heck
is he chained to a tree
no
is he chained to the ground
he gave like
20 000 runes
no he's just got a chain on him okay
wow
probably was easier to reuse the asset
but at that rate maybe you just should
not have done it that's
that's why i find him so confusing i
don't understand like why they did that
i think it was
i think i don't know if it was pascal
who told me this but someone said like
they ran out of money
which i don't know about that like the
games i don't i don't see that
does anyone know how much this game cost
to make
assuming this game is very expensive
what's up falcon as a fellow jake you
love zelda ring i really enjoy your
content and lore breakdowns thanks so
much for making the bits you're welcome
i'm happy you like them
i don't have a damn key
i don't got no key oh we should uh
update our list real quick
we've got who'd we just beat we just
beat god of roy which would be
altus plateau
right here
bang
if you guys want this list it's in the
description by the way
that wasn't me but reusing assets is
still a viable attack to keep costs down
yeah i just
it is a viable tactic they just didn't
need to do it
you know
and they they didn't
they just didn't need to do that
they could have just not had the boss i
think
could have waited
until
the game came out
put god of roy in some dlc or something
right
i don't have a build so i can't put that
in the description
it's just two katanas
die
cheater
dang that [ __ ] hits
whoa
hey cut that out
hang
it i'm gonna die
oh my god
this is bad
i knew that wouldn't reach
i can't roll
i'm dead
actually
okay nope that didn't help
don't kill me
dang it
you need to hit him
that is super helpful advice man thank
you so much
banish knights
are just lothric knights and so on
yeah that's from another game though
like that's that's totally fine i don't
care about that i don't i don't like
that they reused one of the most iconic
bosses in this game
to just make another boss in this area
i don't i don't care if they use lothric
knights from dark souls 3
for the knights in this game that's fine
i don't care about that
but man
let's just slap godric again in this
area you know this is kind of weird
re-fight the boss without having to make
a new character
that's true
then why change his name
right
stop it
[Music]
god this is so fast
damn
one more hit please there we go
it's a typo
can you imagine it's a typo it does say
the grafted as well
i i feel like it's just there to confuse
people
i really do it's like let's just make
this really confusing
screw it
which i you know i don't like that
what up silly what's up caleb
yeah i mean it's a good fight i really
like godric is one of my favorite fights
in the game i don't mind doing it again
but why the hell is he named god of roy
here
there could be a lot of reasons for that
but just don't know for sure i see
you've performed another task for us yes
i did mommy
reward
please well thank you celeste i
appreciate that man
oh i'd like the sword too now
perhaps the time has come to tell you
of the true ruler of this manner
lord reichard
the erd tree blessed the tarnished with
grace
but it was all too meager in the face of
the enormity of their task
the tarnished were forced to scavenge
squabbling for crumbs what's up teff
london how are we doing brother for
power in the wake of the shattering
our lord
indignant
miyazaki's trolling yeah discovery about
fighting over what he's trolling baby
they allow us
if the earth tree
and indeed the very gods would debase us
so
then we are willing to raise the banner
of resistance
even if it means heresy
we at the volcano manor under lord
reichard have sworn no rest until it is
done
if you follow this heroic path
one day the lord will see you
the lord's visits with our champions are
always a spectacle
it cannot come a day too soon they're
just trying to get me eaten
i feel like they kind of uh could have
done more with the volcano manor besides
like these three things and then the
reichard fight
i don't know though
what's up hertz how are you i need a
little bit more i got anything
i got any poppy boys no
they chat
oh
yeah this works
too i was gonna call you beautiful
but uh
i can't
why are people saying bit rates dead
i think your internet's just bad
just as my noble brother says
i'm a complete fool
i can't believe i thought i could become
a champion
i can't believe you thought that either
perhaps i am a fool after all
no it's worse than that
as things stand
i've given up on the path of revenge and
sullied the name of my house
what an easy mark i must have been
perhaps i am a fool after all
no
it's worse than that
as things stand
you can't tell bach that he's beautiful
then he changes his mind my house
what an easy mark i must have been it's
how you can save bach from
being uh turned into a human and dying
so you've blooded your sword in the hunt
then i shall introduce yeah is the
bitrate fine guys is not just being a
troll
a recusant just like you recusants have
particular battle arts
styled to our methods of slaughter
why not add some to your repertoire
repertoire
you've come to understand now hey
to take power and make it his own
the recusant must hunt his own kind
to raise the flag of revolt against this
sanctified pillaging
we recusants must become the most
wretched of predators no issues okay
please laugh
we're all beautiful
it's true
do i want any of these nah we're good
well
until we meet again damn
okay
uh
you think george rr martin just wrote
like 10
yeah we needed another g
so we just added gotta fry in there [ __ ]
it man ah
hello
what impeccable timing
this is for you oh
letter to patches
two patches
but if you complete the request
you can improve your standing
relax
we're old friends
time's come to pass the torch right
go on break a leg then oh god
that's not sus
that really long laugh at the end isn't
suss
at all
letter two patches
great horned tragic tragoth
he can be found at the ruin strewn
precipice
find the red mark on your map for the
exact location is this where he kicks me
into the thing
yep
that's exactly where we're going
you killed patches not a bad kill i'm
not gonna lie not a bad kill
he's a troll
an absolute troll hey can i go here i
don't have the map
shoot
oh it said precipice so i'm going here
perfect
george martin just farted in the room
when eldon ring was written and called
it a day
well i feel like we can definitely tell
that george rr martin
was part of this wouldn't you say
what's back in here
all right what kind of troll is this
gonna be
hello
wrong way
this way
this way
this way
it's above me isn't it
i'm right on this thing
can we even go up here
damn that looks gorgeous up there
do i have to go above me right now
he kicks you before you join the manor i
think i just missed that then
it's near the grace
oh
man that freaking buttons way off then
the heck
that's way off
all right what we got
yep gotta reset
oh
sew [ __ ]
that is a move
this man's pulleys
beyond the beyond
[Music]
just do this all day buddy
dang it maybe not
hold on
stop
yeah i did summon him for the magma worm
fight if i remember it
what slam
i should probably heal
do you guys think that eldon ring
is too big
owned
like would you guys have preferred a
more
bloodborne approach or did you do you
like the insane size of elden ring
because i really like it i i've always
loved open world games so this really
hit with me since i played all the
the souls games before it
that armor is cool
okay nice
it's not big enough i i don't think a
game's ever been bigger so
minus 20 percent of the game is perfect
because i know a lot of people out there
would have liked just another um
another dark souls
thing another bloodborne you know
it's really not that big you are
tripping balls if you don't think this
game's that big
you are tripping
balls
have you played a bigger game than this
is there a game that's bigger than this
one
if you if you guys say minecraft i'll
laugh
because that's true
can i just go over here yeah let's do
that and talk to patches
mountain tops of the giants feels tiny i
mean it's it's the top of a mountain so
it's pretty big
can't just make every area huge you know
overall the game is massive hello again
welcome to patch's emporium
hey i did the thing you'd wanted you
hunted down
are you certain yeah no it's quite all
right
fine work indeed
i'll give tandem do you think our red
dead 2 is bigger some rest by all means
maybe
i don't think so
i mean it might be
can i sell anything do i have any things
no okay stingy little beggar
try to find it in your heart next time
eh
okay bro
okay bro
i play a game called the game we all
lose that sounds sus
it looks small at first but yeah it's
big
well yeah
i mean we all had no idea how big the
game was
until we played it
i'm talking about the entirety of the
map the whole thing
i did have someone in the in
uh one of my comments saying minecraft's
bigger than elden ring
and i'm like well yeah
duh it net i'm pretty sure minecraft's
never ending
should i buy a ps4 just for bloodborne
that's what i did
i just want this map
and i guess we could fight this boss
i would just want this map
leave me alone
i don't like fighting the hands i don't
like it
i don't like it
stay
stay
have you ever hit max level
no because i don't ruin farm
i ain't no [ __ ]
i play the game
to get runes
but if you ruin farm that's fine
i don't care
excellent
i don't know if i want to fight this
thing on torrent
let's not
let me get your head
i'm bad
how could you be late yoda
how could you ever be late
i can't what is he
what's going
on what the
i can't i can't hit him
thank you
stop going up here
oh man
wow that staggered the [ __ ] out of me
wow cool
if he does the thing i'm dead
fall off the mountain
like
i have no words
for what's happening
at least the music's good right
now
please don't kill me
okay
oh
at least the music's good
but man
that is uh
not the best fight
get stuck in the tree
okay
sorry okay
clap we did it
updating the list
that was
mount glamiere
and it was the tree spirit
we're kind of all over the place right
now should we just go to caled or the
lake and do all of these things what do
you guys want to do
so i feel like we should go in order
of some kind
because last episode
last time we streamed i was focused on
quests and now i think we gotta we gotta
catch up on some bosses
lake dude don't go to caleb i mean we
already beat radon
so
we're good there we can go to the lake
though absolutely
all right we'll go to the lake you guys
seem to like the lake except for dream
dream likes caitlyn
let's go to
[Music]
let's go here
start all the way back did you just
reject retracted it
you guys really like the lake
the lake is cool
i had a poppin all right let's go this
way
w
have you killed the snail
no
not yet
not yet
i don't have enough
bruh
all right
we continue on
isn't the snail in the mountain tops
we haven't been there yet
that's the best view in the game right
up there
what's your favorite type of build
i don't really have a favorite
i just like messing around
i would say bleed builds are the best
but i wouldn't say they're my favorite
we do anything new
uh we went to volcano manor for a minute
i just like smacking all these people
we beat the tree spirit
but nothing nothing crazy there
i really need to research these puppets
yeah i don't have a favorite
i don't have a favorite weapon i don't
have a favorite build
i just kind of like playing the game
i need to research these things right
here
because they're creepy
a dog
i was really wrong about this being a
dog
turtle dog
i was way off on that that was some
puppets butthole
this takes you to the gate right
we can come right back here this one i
don't want to check
it ruined your new game plus why
yep
i was right
but
now we go back
didn't it look like a turtle shell at
first
it did
wharf son of moog bleed flame strength
build
that's sick
i've thought about doing that
i think we decided on a radon build for
this one we just have to get more levels
to be able to do that
what does this guy say ah the puppets
the puppets besiege us
the puppets
i'm pretty sure that was the puppets
butthole but
we can go with it there's still some
more stuff over here
we got a battle going on over her
we don't need to get involved
yeah yeah yeah i think we want to do a
radon building
even i'll even get his bow and arrow
but we gotta get a lot of levels to be
able to even do that so
i think a bunch of things just pop up
here yep oh
growing up
everything's a dog
exactly
exactly
we got here
all right a cookbook that no one uses
nice
be honest how many times have you guys
crafted in this game
be honest
oh nice
zero times
exactly
okay
we go down there
i don't think i've ever oh i know where
we can go
we can go down under
go back over here
we can go see jar baron
and alexander should be stuck over here
or that way but let's let's check over
here first
where do you point
ah
i have already partook
in the radon festival
and beat his butt
that man dead
[Music]
i do the thumbnails
but the art
is in the description
now we could go to knox stella
i don't want to do a lore video on
soldier of godric okay
he's one of godric soldiers there
there's your video
you guys ask me that every stream
there's nothing to him
he's nothing
then someone will say he's the most
powerful
enemy in the game
that's a good video idea crimson
april fool's joke
all right i'll wait a year did i buy a
lantern i did
i'm so smart
wow didn't see that coming
wow
okay
i hate these things bro i hate them
i hate them
resin got some violets
soldier of god
rick
exactly
four playthroughs and i've never been in
this dungeon
welcome to the elden ring experience
where every time you play the game you
find something new
that's a big sword you got there
it's too bad you're dead now
um okay what do we got what are we
rocking with here
i made a whole video on let me solo her
i don't know what let me solo me is
i hate you
got him
actual run is uh for the flame frenzy
ending i just remembered i don't have
the talisman that alexander drops before
consuming radon it's a sad face
without my favorite pot
that is true
that is true
let me solo me i don't know what that is
no
no idea
isn't there an omen down here
yeah
well
that was easier than expected
why is there an omen down
here how do you get out
there's two
let me solo me as a guy using supuku
until his own
are you serious
does he look exactly the same as uh let
me solo her
it's kind of funny
ow
oh this is not good i don't want to be
here
this one is so aggressive
okay
let's not step on it again almost did
anyway
i wouldn't even say i'm good at this
game man
i've just played it a lot
letting to feel her so everyone's just
copying
let me solo here then right
nerd
i would say another gripe i have with
this game i don't have that many but
another one i could think of is i don't
think these dungeons are very creative
they all kind of look the same they have
different layouts but they all kind of
look the same
exactly killa you're you're never really
good at the game even though the entire
community is like just get good bro
you're never really good you're just
experienced that's exactly right
swing the sword man did you see how long
he held that
oh this is bad
oh no
i don't want oh no
i backed myself into a corner
we're gonna get out of this
maybe not
heal once
is there another one
huh
see that that was bad that that was
scary
oh okay
oh
but yeah one of my least favorite
enemies in this game are those freaking
imps bro
i'm kind of confused how omens are
banished to the sewers if they're born
from royalty but there isn't that much
of royalty if there's so many
if there's just that many almonds in the
sewers
i mean not gonna lie bro like probably
all those almonds that you see that
still have horns
are probably like
children
of america
that they just discarded
it's like oh that wouldn't work
they just throw it away it's really sad
sorry i'm looking for a trap
i've already been here how do i get how
do i get over here
melana is margaret the fel omen she
doesn't mention him before the castle
for godric but says after fighting
margaret
margat that she was testing us she would
have fought with them
ooh
fought with us
interesting
i don't think that's true at all but
i like it it's very interesting do i
have to go over here
this is a fake wall
nope
so from all the builds you have done
which one's your favorite to play
uh
[Music]
probably bleed build like rivers of
blood how do we get over there chat i
need to get right there
do i have to drop
that's someone i've killed
i just backtracked
oh no
bling bling bling
i don't think i have a stone sword key
to use here
i don't really know if i want to waste
it on this if i do have one
no
i remember that thing in there not being
that good
oh
a rooney boy
screw it
how was your day with joy it was the
best day ever
i love hanging out with joy
all day
joy is the best
i'm lost
get some elden bling yeah i probably
should i'm still rocking the samurai
stuff aren't i
welcome ced i'm glad you like him bro
how the hell do i get over there man
what do i do
do i have to drop down
oh
sketch
oh
if i drop down do i die
ow
nerd
i shouldn't have [ __ ] around
okay
i got way too confident way too
confident
hey cd becoming a tarnish man thank you
very much
thanks for becoming a member dude i
appreciate you
thank you thank you thank you
why are there almonds in here
kick me
kick you
dang he completely disappeared in that
bush
oh
wonderful
that
just
man that was unsettling
oh i hear some [ __ ] though
but thank you cd i appreciate you man
enjoy your badge
enjoy your emotes that nobody uses in
here
because y'all are
cringe
nice game
nice game miyazaki
well now you're affected
i'm so smart
i'm so smart
there you go now you guys are using them
there it is
thanks sometimes i have to make fun of
you
oh i wouldn't say that
he became a member before he subbed i
love it thank you man
welcome
uh my theories that eldon ring was made
by a madman called hide your tacos
miyazaki and it was all an elaborate it
was all in elaborate to make dark souls
lore deeper
nice
i i feel like we could just say anything
about the lore of this game and everyone
could just be like well yeah that
actually could be true
i still like
let me know if you guys still feel this
way i don't have enough evidence to like
make a video on this theory but i think
the entire world of elden ring is a
dream it's not even real
none of it's real
some dream
some purgatory world
i haven't played gary's mod since i was
a kid
oh that's kind of cool
we're 100 in every quest line and boss
fight
we live in a simulation
that's true
it's true
oh that was
was that the door opening that loud
god damn
that's bloodborne though
the hunter's dream yeah
true
true
it's bait on judo christian religion
do we know that
oh god
archery burial watchdog
terrifying
stop
terrifying
ah
they're so scary
hayden sellsword acid that sounds sick
all right let's get it
yeah it's in the description dj
the death within
okay that was
we're in the lakes
that was
burial watchdog right cliff bottom
i think that's where we are okay
easy enemy but yeah it's just stressful
because of like you can't really read
its movements very well because it's
like a robot bro
it's like a freaking robot
okay
by the way i'm just putting levels into
anything because i know that we're just
gonna go and re-format them at ranala
whenever we pick our weapon right now
we're just trying to get levels
okay let's go down under
no we're i think we're gonna do a radon
build that seems to be what everybody
wants but we can
i can see what everyone's vibing with
later on
what kind of dog is that i think it's a
cat
i think it's a cat
but
young
watch if i did that it just keeled over
and died
it's like
yeah why is it called a watchdog when it
looks like a cat
i'm not killing the dog i won't do it i
refuse
it's the only thing i i refuse to kill
all right is alexander stuck over here
we gotta lube him up
oh he's not here yet all right
i wonder why
okay we got the jarry boys down here
you guys ready to be called cause over
and over again
don't worry cause
don't worry cause
it's a cat which is a type of dog
great
i wasn't already confused about
everything else
i did the radon fight but maybe i didn't
do all of uh his dialogue we can go back
and do that
because he should be there
hey cars hello coz
what are you doing here i don't know i
didn't think anyone knew about this
place i didn't except us jars
ah
are you going to be the new potentate
sure
absolutely i'll be that i don't know
what it is but i'll do it gosh
truly
that's wonderful news
it's not easy being potentate though
i know
show me your hands it's just a little
test cuz
i will never kill jar baron you guys are
nuts
wanting to do that
your skin
isn't so smooth
is it
you need slick slidy hands rude
you know
i'm sorry cuz
but i don't think you've got what it
takes yeah it's down here
that's a shame cars don't look so glum
because
we can still chat
potentially or not
come back and visit me
when you can
don't look so we can still okay
i don't know if i want to do this yet
because it's all just kind of uh
well let's get alexander up top first
it's pretty much just getting dialogue
over and over again it's not like super
fun he's not here
he would say his name here if he was
here
is this a dog do you guys think
everything is a dog
yeah he's not here guys
uh-oh
where the hell is he
oh let's go to this one over here
is jake a dog
i could be
do y'all even know what i look like
yeah is he is he at mount glimmer lemire
it's either everything's a dog or
nothing all right fair enough
yeah it's a dog obviously
how do i get to that random i'll figure
it out we'll figure it out right now
let's focus on this
what's your favorite weapon i don't
really have one
i just like playing the game
i imagine you're six foot eight jacked
with a jawline
that could cut diamonds
i like the way you think
um
where's my og twitch oh it's king
and yusuf what's up guys
that is og twitch gang
all five of you guys
oh [ __ ] here we go again
just going to ignore that
[Music]
you guys do your thing i'll be over here
doing mine
whoa
hey a chest
is that all we got down here
no
there we go
how's uh
i was enjoying youtube yes very much i
like youtube much more than twitch
oh good
oh oh good
i avoided all of the radon and melania
warriors out there
but an imp can grab me in the back and
one shot me that's great
it's [ __ ] imps man i got morbed
why don't you keep your katanas and
focus on the ashes of war
i don't know
i'm just playing the [ __ ] game bro
ignore me thank you
what [ __ ] you guys
[ __ ] the imps not you guys that's all
that's down here
what is this
please leave me be
i ain't even messing
ah
oh this isn't good
bye guys what what is this guy doing
what are you doing bro
oh these guys are taking some hits
we may not want to be here
oh god
you found me
we gotta get up there
owie
what the
man
oh god
i'm not a part of this
keep fighting
i see
what are these radon
i know there is warriors
oh you have another version of that i
see
this ain't good boys
this this is actually quite bad
i don't know whether that's where i need
to go or not
so i'm a little scared to jump
okay at least we know
where to go
you're stuck here for three days
my god
all right i'm gonna figure it out right
now we're not gonna die again
this is it
what's the boss at the end of this one
try fingers butthole
nice shot idiot
there's a tree spirit at the end of this
oh it's so
bad oh god
stop stop
this where it is oh frig i did not mean
to jump
all right it can't hurt
oh my god
[Music]
i don't know if we want to be here guys
um
i got morbed
kill stuff
i don't think we're strong enough to hit
any of these things
i love that though
bro just hit him
just hit him bro
get good bro
what's your real name
what do you guys think my real name is
you stay
just looking for [ __ ] all right
you guys think my name is jake
it might not be
the hell is the end of this place
nice
i found it
jack
shabriri
short for jake mundo
it's short for wumbo
jake nathaniel barbs
okay
yeah my name is actually agent
my first name agent last name jake
i need to know your name i don't want to
guess
but what if i just didn't tell you
maybe i just like the name jake
and i use it as an alias
oh son of a [ __ ]
i just fought one of these things
i'm not strong enough am i
i'm barely doing anything to this guy
oh it's a tail swipe huh
doing a lot of damage yeah
i uh
we need to come back here i didn't
realize like why is
why is this area harder than radon
all right guys i'm gonna be a [ __ ]
check it out wait wait
i'm doing it
the twig is on
i have actually equipped the twig
hey i know when i'm not strong enough to
beat something and i that's not
happening
i will call you dog from now on
all right
how about this
my name is jake
or jacob
oh my god
i just let me get to my
dude okay
but how do you think i spell it
that's right j-a-d-o-g
no the twig
oh
i don't even think it's worth it to stab
him there
son of a beach
oh
stop swinging you idiot oh god
no idea what's happening or how i'm
alive
really
oh really
that's what we want baby
that's not though
no
i rolled
[Music]
i rolled
i made one mistake bro well no i got hit
a lot actually
but we got the twig
we got the twig though
i don't have another twig
all right i'm gonna do a pull
i'ma let you guys pick
do we go again
yes
or no
i would have wasted a twig
and
i might lose my runes
but i'm doing a poll
do we go again
democracy at its finest
actually can i spend all these
i don't even know why i did a poll
because you're gonna say yes damn it
i got one poppy boy
that might have been enough
like 150 off
oh my god
um
all right let's wait for one of these
guys to die
i don't think i can even kill him
you yes i like this
oh hell yeah bro here we go
now i'm fine with it now we go back and
fight
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they give
you like a thousand runes too that's big
except they're hard to beat
boom
health
level vigor
all right i'll end that poll because i
don't i don't even know why i did that
because i know what the hell you guys
are gonna do i know what you're gonna
say
yes
what up
uh we could probably upgrade we're gonna
have to wait though
we can we can beat him
we can beat him
i almost did
oh you guys know rune farm areas
all right how many of you guys actually
do room rune farming
i've never done it
hey you do whatever you want it don't
matter i just don't like it i like
playing the game to get runes
i hate that attack
i hate that attack
isn't going as
well i like this let's keep dancing and
going to the left
good
i freaking rolled man
apparently i am rolling too late
i'm rolling too late
yeah you still play the game still
i just don't like rune farming
i don't find it very enjoyable so i
don't do it
but if you do
all the power to you
i just leveled health
listen i could have like 60 bigger and i
died of this thing in two hits
so it don't matter
it don't matter none
what
is that
okay that's not fair oh god
didn't get the bleed but we're closer
i'm trying to run and he's not doing it
gotta be close to the bleed
oh no
oh no
the the lock on just turned off and
wouldn't go back on
man this sucks
gotta do it though
we did a whole stream last month where
we died in melania for five hours
it was great
you ever fought a tree spirit
yes
yes
i have
dude we're almost at 55k
how many more
we do we need like two more subs for 55k
you can't read it
i don't have stamina that's why that
happened okay
oh come on
can't
tell what it's doing
these fights suck
okay
i rolled
come on baby
i should have waited to use this
all right fair enough
i don't understand that
no bleed
what are you doing
okay
are you it goes this far back
that's
[Music]
come on jake
come on baby
[ __ ]
got him
more runes than we're done
get more runes for that than from radon
that's nuts
gg
i knew we could do it the entire time
didn't have to use every flask i have
nope
nope
we were fine
i've been reading the lore i'm starting
to think that place deus ex were the
dragon versions of the elden word he
characterized as the elder dragon uh i
believe that's true
that uh the dragons were
once
the elden lord
chat or jake the chat wants to know
melania smasher pass
bro she's got
probably the worst
like sexually transmitted disease you
can get
you guys telling me you'd smash
all right we're pulling it
starting the poll
so you guys are risking getting scarlet
rot to smash
yeah she probably smells bro
she's been asleep for a thousand years
you guys are gross
let's see if we can go upgrade
you need an unalloyed gold condom
that's funny
good one aiden that's funny
oh man bro
that's that's a good one
that's not bad
i don't think i want any of these do we
know
look how you boy here
she's crestfallen and can scarcely swing
she reminds me too much of amber heard
both rotting from the inside and hell
been on destroying everything they touch
their eyes share the same hue
that's pretty good too
you guys are creative on youtube man
i see you've noticed to change
nothing special
i'm a prisoner and these are my chains
more than half of you are saying yes
i'm dying smithing for you fools
that's all there is to it
no cap
they're not melania's not real chet
they're not
real oh now we got bots
that's our fault for doing the smasher
pass poll
the bots come out as soon as we [ __ ]
do that of course
we haven't done fia yet should probably
talk to her greetings great champion
called by grace
i am fear
circumstances have compelled my stay at
the round table hold great champion
would you allow me to hold you
but briefly
perhaps you might share with me they
smell it love your life
and your stout-heartedness
doing so will grant me the warmth of a
champion
and you
i am sure
it's not yoda they're just named
something very similar
perhaps
where i come from
it is a sacred act
yes or no chad do i let her hold me
i actually have to so never mind my
thanks
great champion
time for finger
but whole
i want a hug like this this is a great
hug you are
very warm
what you felt light up inside you was a
baldicon's blessing though it is a
fleeting thing i am afraid
come back to me
should you require another i will take
you in my arms
as often as you need
another one
yay
freaking weirdos
report
um
[Music]
bang
do they go away for that no we got to do
this
bang
they go
man that's my only gripe with youtube
youtube streaming are the bots
everything else has been great
what are we doing ending wise that'll be
up to the chat at the end of the game
probably talk to me
hello again you haven't gone to see
garand yet have you yeah they have
different emails yoda no rush
you do as you please
just as long as he doesn't starve to
death you can have the same name as
someone you just have to have a
different email
okay we're not even close to the end of
the game so we can wait we can wait i
don't know why i'm talking to him again
i am pleased to see you again
would you like me to hold you
once more the blessing is still a flame
in your breast dear
would you like to be held
regardless
yes wait i have to uh i have to rest
first
also i can talk to rodericka
rodericka greetings
nice to see you is she taller than me
dude she is i should have told you
sooner isn't this place impressive god
damn it round table hold
cover quarters of the two like the same
height
and gathering place of champions who vie
to become elder lord
i never knew the guidance bestowed upon
she's not standing on anything she's
just taller than me
it's like the same i it's all a bit much
for me in truth
i'm still looking for my own purpose
you're telling me i possess some kind of
gift
i don't believe you
i think you got a cuddle with her twice
sir i do have this talent what's up
farmer and goodness knows it would be my
first
i suppose i should try to hone it
shouldn't i i'll ask master hugh to
teach me
certainly he does appear intimidating
and holds no love for us tarnished
but i know he's trapped here at the
round table hold
so
i can tell she's not into shorter guys
damn it underneath it
because roderick is pretty cool
but uh
we she might be taller than me but
i mean come on right
look at his body
damn
dude she's taller than me all right i'm
over it
i'm over it
it's fine
she can be taller than me
it's fine
it's a weird get up but
looks cool
them cheeks though
oh wait now we rest
you see that body chat peak pinnacle
giga chad
she has heels on
still i am pleased to see you again
would you like me to hold you
once more the blessing is still would
you liked yes
uh the real reason you won't smash
melania just isn't because of the rod
it's because she's twice your size
both
i don't know who either those people are
piggy so now very warm
she's really into being warm i was known
as a deathbed companion
was known
after i received the warmth and lifely
figure
from a number of champions
i lay
with the remains of an exalted noble
to grant him another chance at life i
think we need 18 more subs for 55k
which is big i could bear the noble into
new life
i was awakened
by the guidance of grace big
and chaste from my birthplace
pray
be kind
despite all that
i still wish to be a deathbed companion
so please
i know you can only sub once
as often as it takes
i'm just saying my dear
might i ask something of you
could you please find the owner of this
dagger
i want to get to 100k before the end of
the year that's my goal is 100k by the
end of the year
a certain person gave it to me
as a gift what's the laura fear
dead people that's what she does
in the owner's heart she [ __ ] godly for
the original owner to have it back
if you wouldn't mind i should do a video
on fia i'd like you to find it okay we
already said that though
then good day to you my dear let go of
me mom
why
because it makes her feel warm
stop saying you'd smash everyone in the
game bro
bonk
i mean leonel would be a part of fia's
video i would imagine go to garank only
if you feel the time is right
killing those who live in death and
weeding their death root
is a path not to be trod without ample
resolve
well
what have we here
how did you get your hands on that
dagger
gee the breathing my god that hardly
matters
i know very well whose dagger it is
why don't i return it to them for you
good work i'll smash grunk
you guys would smash anybody in the game
just say that would you smash anybody in
this game
all right he's gone he's dead as hell
right over here
he's dead as hell
lol
so you guys would smash huh the heck
that's what happens if you smash
there's your answer
you guys cool with that
finally
it is returned to its rightful place and
she doesn't know where i am
there we go of the exalted noble worth
it
i must beat you goodbye it might seem so
horny
this video is getting demonetized that's
fine
deathbed companion
heart round table
disturb not the death of godwin
the exalted we look how weird she
live in disappears
to one day
welcome our lord
what right does anyone have to object
not me i don't give a [ __ ] rise
the lord of the many
and the meek
she gone
one night stan
yeah fia's questline is dope
that's one of the first videos that
actually really popped off from my
channel was doing uh
a guide
on how to do fia's quest line it got
like a quarter million views that's like
one of my first big ones
can you imagine if she fortnight danced
on your body and then left
on d's body and just pieced
what if i do
hold on
has anyone experimented with doing these
like i know it works on bach
but do they work on other people
she did not care at all if i do have a
talent for spirit tuning
i'm 27 christians
i suppose i'm glad you like him reboot
shouldn't i i'll ask master hugh to
teach me
good
good
why are you not over there yet
hey
because i might wanna i might wanna use
a summon
because now the game starts getting hard
without your arms
are you out of your mind
who'd stay with an ugly brute you tried
everyone okay
i figured someone out there would
besides she'd never agree to it
i refuse to believe it
i don't doubt you but i know when
something's too good to be true huge so
sad no
don't read too much into it
well no grudge against you
my being a prisoner is no fault of yours
besides
my own mind smithing
despite my differences the weapons get
stronger all the same
given time yet you're always hitting the
same sword
besides it helps me forget
the sheer terror of her
all right let's see
i don't even know what kind of spirits
we got we could we could get one and
upgrade it pretty good i think
based on where we've been
nope we're just doing all quest lines
and bosses good to see you again
thank you very much
i have you to thank don't i
for persuading master hugh yeah that was
me
but he has taught me the noble toil of
spirit tuning
i'm as yet unsure of what i might be
able to accomplish i've had to ban a few
of them kyle i might be able to help you
all
it's all good they're easy and if
there's any chance to ease this tried
law of aggression on nicolas cocoon
corpse archery nothing happens
rodrika the spirit tune apprentice
pleased to make your acquaintance
there's something you should know i need
to warn you about something oh we got a
little while ago someone started the
dung eater
and i can hear
from all the way over there
the howling and wailing of spirits in
fear of a curse
i can even hear the repulsive twisted
malice in itself
a plethora of spirits
[Music]
not even the grafting caused anything
like this to happen
you should keep your distance i know
you're strong but please
what
you
you bought
kill
die
there okay thank you
i don't gotten oh i do okay
are any of these good
oh we got a lot of them okay
we got oleg we got egg egg ball
we got latana
redmayne knight ooga
ooga chukka
we got the headless we got a bird
we got a bird
can i help on ronaldo we already killed
granola
um these look cool
that looks sick um
i already have plus wait why are all
these plus one already
oh because it's level one okay i'm
stupid
i use banish knight all the time he's
legit this one yeah i've heard oleg's
lit
let's do it
damn
son okay
okay wait i can just talk greetings are
you here for spirit
i feel like i'm really coming to grips
with spirit tuning of late
i can see how and why you
another one
kyle
nice good [ __ ] kyle understand their
yearnings
what they become drawn to
master hughes said it himself actually
that i'm no mere apprentice any longer
once again i'm pleased to make your
acquaintance the disgusting fast food
eta
welcome back king welcome back all right
let's go talk to the dump
i can curtsy
i don't think i've ever had that
nice
we do love cheap sex
i mean if you guys are
you know
you want to smash fia
and melania
probably
what up dog eater
stupid head
you guys you guys notice that he's
bleeding out of his [ __ ] while he's
sitting here
gross have you ever felt the curse
with your whole being
the box upon life itself
feared
and despised by all
the reviled blessing
apparently not
you all but a lamb
it's diarrhea strange as it
ignorance of your own ignorance
you no longer interest me
i've been long without peace
don't spoil my quiet dude
do you guys think they just made words
up for this game
have you guys ever in your entire life
heard the word quiet food
i think they just made that [ __ ] up but
we know what it means
i know what it means
let me get here
now we need threes okay
you have
i haven't
all right get in get in how we how we
how we thinking here you'll be after
more great rooms now eh yeah
then as your fellow allow me to divulge
a little knowledge
bogus
there it is boys
oh thank you guys
appreciate you
alright so we know everything he says
here
what do we do now what do you guys want
to do what do we do how do we do it what
do we do what do we do hmm
i could go grab that really quick while
we think of it
just to get all the maps
we reached 55k together
we shall devour the very gods
oh we could go in there we should do
that actually
you remember when i said like oh yeah
let's go to the lake and now i'm just
completely distracted with other [ __ ]
hey thank you silly uh oh i don't want
that to happen again silly thank you bro
appreciate you becoming a tarnished
welcome to the family
yay
oh [ __ ] i was looking at chat all right
that's a somber eight right there guys
that's an eight banger
then we get a nine banger right down
here
we oh god
whoo that was close to being really bad
that's not what i wanted to do
runarch nine banger
family together
we shall devour the very god
i think i could have been reichard i
could have voiced striker what do you
think
i noticed last night after finding the
moog blood palace you can tell gideon
about it and he gives you a crafting
book that allows you to craft the
bewitching branch thoughts on the branch
what is um
is the wishing branch just like
how you can save runes
right
we shall devour the very claw
i think that was right on
that was perfect
yo what up nerd
you did
never get my first play through the
whole two weeks i didn't even
i didn't know where to go for ranala
you never had like got curious of going
into the academy really
that's surprising
arthur morgan oh that's
i don't know that's that's a twitch
thing
guys played red dead too do you guys
know what arthur morgan sounds like
i don't even know what other games my
community's into what what games do you
guys play right now besides elden ring
or is it just elven ring
yeah
i don't know about that
yeah
that doesn't sound too good john
that was so much arthur morgan just goes
yeah i know
okay
sure
you guys actually do play rocket league
okay
i've had like no
want to play rocket league at all
even though i have 7 500 hours in that
game i haven't played it in six months
come on dutch
come on now
let's go
we can come back to that later
for now
oh god the last thing i ever want to
hear ever again is someone telling me
they can flip reset more than me
last of us is a great game great game
ghost to shima is a fantastic
fantastic game
really is
howdy there partner
yeah
i tried playing remnant from the ashes
and i wasn't a huge
huge fan
radon's rune
gonna examine this thing
um yes
indeed
a rune
nicey
now we gotta go back down
i cried when my horse died in red dead
too as well that's just sad
ah yes a 2d circle
impressive
ow
lol get wrecked idiots
hey god of war came out on a pc
it was a great time we played the [ __ ]
out of that game whenever it came out on
pc
all right i'm gonna trust you guys
can i just roll and land on this thing
or do i have to jump
i think i can just roll
we have our answer
you can just walk
[Music]
we've got our answer
we did
[ __ ]
i don't know why that scared me because
i just did that
should have done a pull all right i'm
gonna walk it
you guys are great
you guys are the best
oh what the
who can move midair
how did he get here
why did
what the [ __ ]
the laws of physics mean nothing
my character just went off to the right
midair
all right all right all right
no more [ __ ] about
uh only the tarnished is that in the
lore
and the lore
okay i got scared
there you go
much better
okay you turd monkey
i don't want to talk about how close
that was
eldon ring over fortnight
all right what's better chat elden ring
or fortnite
i ask you guys a lot of stupid questions
don't i
the answer better be fortnite
i love fortnite
fortnite's my favorite game
my mom gave me some v bucks
and i bought the battle pass
but alden rings too expensive for me to
buy because it's a 60 game and i only
play free-to-play games like fortnight
um
but i think i've spent like five
thousand dollars in v bucks
would you rather have godfrey or ratagon
is your dad definitely godfrey godfrey's
lit
also why do we survive these falls
randomly
what what there's nothing here
like why do we survive that
two of them
hey you guys got uno on your xbox
yeah i want muriel as my dad
if eldon ring comes out with a battle
pass
if eldon ring comes out with a battle
pass i will stream fortnite
there
i'll do it
we can use our mimic boy for this fight
i haven't had a talisman
this whole time
[Music]
oh there we go
patches as your dad that's kind of suss
ibaka
i didn't equip the thing i wanted to
equip did i
that's really cool
a quippy
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
i thought it would hit him
let's go oleg
holy [ __ ]
still going after me
dang he hits
okay
okay only got messed up bro he got
messed up
i wanted that bleed baby i got the bleed
[Music]
[Music]
oh
risky
jake's too humble to admit that he
recorded
yep that guys the the the the godskin
music is me
thank you justice
what's up man
that's me bro
i did that
rl is not okay
oh wait are we still talking about rocky
i re i really like this fight
music as well why can't i use oleg oleg
[Music]
what
why can't i use oleg
what
[Music]
dude he hits for so much damage holy
[ __ ]
i had full fp
oh
i used a great rune didn't i
or not a great rune
an art rune arc
that's what it was
[Music]
thought he was gonna do the spinny thing
bro
[Music]
i was popping off for a second there
[Music]
[Music]
got the bleed but took a hit
take another hit
not bad
oh [ __ ]
the moment i say not bad
the moment
they have so much health and they do a
[ __ ] ton of damage
okay here
now we got oleg
we got this
don't die you guys are great at helping
you're the best
that's fine i'll take that hit i don't
care
no don't do that oleg
he's going for the guy
oh my god
bro the timing there
oleg
come over here
yes
that's what we want baby get that bleed
get a bleed get a bleed yes
very nice
that was kind of dumb oh like no cap
that's unfortunate
only got rocked
[Music]
whoa that attack is cool
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on bro all right
why do we do that
back up back up
dude that reach
dead
nice
there are lower reason as to why the god
skins are divine are guarding the divine
towers
um probably
to protect
destin death
from us getting stronger to release dust
and death that's my guess
but
yeah
because i still think they worked for
the glomide queen but then betrayed the
glomite queen and now they don't want
death back
so they can keep i don't know
there's a like
i do know but it's not like
it's hard to explain
i need to like think about it
it has to do with death and death and
they're guarding it
they're linked to
the towers in some way
also have 106k runes right now like what
the hell
which demigod do you think is the most
passionate kisser
probably radon because he's
a good good boy
he's a good boy
um it really doesn't matter
uh go watch my video on death and death
that's pretty much all about the glomide
queen
i made that a while back
and do more endurance
can i wear radon [ __ ] now
probably not
light load
medium load
medium load
heavy load so let's change up the pants
that's a bit odd
[Music]
oh nice okay
jake will you be my senpai
i already am you just didn't know it
should go kill uh the snakey boy oh
let's update update our thing
we just killed
godskin apostle
guild radon
what are those
okay we haven't really done that much
in terms of bosses
who in eldon ring is not a selfish lover
uh america
she don't give a [ __ ]
what is torrance motives sounds dumb
but he is the one who picked us to begin
with he did pick us
torrent doesn't tell us [ __ ] though
well
there's been an age since i've seen a
customer
how can i help here at the end of the
earth
the end of the earth he says really
cool
that's where you get the samurai armor
beast repellent torch
i think we're good have a safe journey
become elden steed
i think we need to go to the capitol
the reason that i'm not killing reichard
yet is because we should have an opening
uh for a quest line with bernal
once we do get in
i think we have to
i don't know we don't have to get in
first
we should just be able to talk to bernal
because we've done two of them two of
the assassinations
did you kill the bell bearing hunter and
kayla already no
where is that
if you follow this it cannot come it
cannot come a day too soon oh my god
is america good or bad depends on
depends
i already talked to you we're the
tarnished yes
a recusant through and through
i knew you had it in you
take this
that's what we want right there a
special invitation
to hunt some of the first tarnished who
sat at the round table hold
if you should accept
i'll next see you on the field of battle
oh the merchant i was just at but at
night okay let's go do that
um and then we can go into the city
and do bernal's thing okay that's that's
good that's good that's good
that was
way up here
sometimes she does bad things but also
she does things that can help us
so i'm confused exactly my guy
that's exactly right
see do i have temporarily boost poise uh
eliminates all fp consumption
i probably like that over that and then
i'm not big on the
health going up a little bit over time
do you think what do you think are don's
motivations for holding the scars stars
and stasis
i personally think that radon was
holding ronnie's two fingers in the sky
uh to stop her from doing what she wants
to do
but
that's that's my theory
i think the two fingers went crashing
down as soon as we kill radon that's why
we see her in the moonlight altar
in that giant hole and then ronnie
finished it off by killing it with the
uh the blade that we give her
and then there's a lot of other reasons
like you could have been holding up the
you know the beast the falling star
beasts in the sky astol
could be reasons that we don't know
about
all right what do i got to do do i have
to come back
oh it just stopped raining i got
confused
there we go
dude the way he sounds coming out sounds
sick
what is this damage
hello
what the [ __ ]
okay
i got annihilated that wasn't even close
i barely hurt him
oh my god
he wants my bell bad
i've tried his weapon before and i don't
think it's very good
i just hit him a bunch of times didn't
do [ __ ] why am i
bruh
wow
i i don't know about this one chat
that's gonna be too much that that's
gonna be too much bro
that that's way too much we're we're not
ready for that at all
no shot
yeah our damage sucks
let's go
get my favorite armor set in the game
well
it is my favorite armor set let's just
go up here let's go let's go
yeah we gotta come back later to that
that's too much like
i bet if we took our time and really
like tried to learn his entire moveset
we could do it eventually but we don't
we just don't need to
jake out of all the demi-god children
step children who would you have who
would you rather have as your siblings
uh
radon
ronnie
and
morgot's kind of a [ __ ]
[Music]
michela
i don't know enough about nicola
everyone seems to like mikola
well i don't know mikola
we don't know anything about godwin
if ronnie was your sister you'd feel so
cocked
all right oleg
oh [ __ ] never mind
i'll do it myself
this [ __ ] donkey
donkey horse
that freaking delay man
foreign
oh the timing of the swings
so hard
okay
and then that one he does fast
don't get it
so
it's gonna be close
[Music]
really
bro i am
what
oh god
the shield
the shield
we got one bleed proc out of that too
dude
all right i'm gonna pop a rooney boy
we're gonna get oleg and we're gonna be
fine
jake you happy about johnny depp winning
the case
yes
very happy
i followed that whole thing
but yes
yeah i'm not a huge
not a huge fan of this boss fight to be
honest
it's all right
i don't got an upgraded hollow bird bro
albert
nice
oh we're still going after me i see okay
okay okay
oh
now
there it is
[Music]
that [ __ ] attack is so annoying
i don't even know how that hit me
there we go
that was my fault
popped off
jesus
oh
we got a bot
we got a bot get out of here
gross
gross
real elden wing players don't have sex
all right we did it that wasn't bad
wasn't good but it wasn't bad
we'll take it
opinion on levi ackermann
levi is poggers
why have sex when you can become elden
lord that's what i'm saying
you guys get it
you guys know what's going on huh
probably need to increase strength
how do you guys feel about seniors in
the workplace saying you can call them
by their first name
i mean if that's what they want
why not
thank you skeleton what ending are we
doing whatever chat wants whenever we
get to the end
i'll have you guys decide
go to godric's arena why
is that where
is nafeli there now
ronnie's mid
i'm pretty sure ronnie is the strongest
character in this game
the philly appears after morgot
my utmost thanks
for bringing me to the base of the tree
it's mommy yeah
mommy made him govern my own movement
and thus
the accord is fulfilled three fingers
the strongest
i don't know
you can kill the three fingers with a
needle
i shall leave torrent
and the power to turn runes into
strength
here
with you
i wish you luck
in realizing your ambition you have
fought long
and hard
long and hard
you will become that's what she said
may you take the throne
ronnie's just a spirit she can still one
tap us
i don't know if you guys have ever seen
that before but if you annoy her enough
she [ __ ] one taps you
you die
immediately
we still got to talk to bach man
all right where's bach
[Music]
[ __ ] you know what no let's let's do
bernal and then we'll do bach or
whatever
we're just going with the flow
no particular order of anything we're
just doing it
[Music]
just doing it baby
speedrun tactic by the way
[Music]
oh god
you know what this thing doesn't count
as a boss i'm running right past it
i'm glad you like the editing lone wolf
that makes me happy
are we forgetting godric
as the
strongest i don't know about that
for my understanding of godric he's kind
of a [ __ ]
oh soldier of godric
of course how can i forget
godric's nothing more than a country
jumped up pumpkin
lord
don't make me laugh
first he insulted melania
then hid amongst the women folk inside
of that castle
that's not the right wording
i could be kind of tight though
i don't know why i'm fighting this guy i
don't need to
i love getting gravel
kenneth is kind of weird
a very underutilized character
very underutilized character
melania blade of michola
how many times you guys heard that
melania blade of mickela
how long did it take you guys to beat
melania first playthrough and be honest
it was a lot right
[Music]
go over here we can do bernal's little
quest
three tries
a million
oh here we go
this is my favorite armor set in the
game whenever we beat this
now rot
that's a big poll you have there
vargram
whoa that could have been really bad
[ __ ]
oh good [ __ ]
i don't even have to do it
there we go
not gonna lie melania is kind of bad in
a good way
you mean like her intentions or like
do you mean bad like she hot
i'm always kind of a [ __ ] for the promo
armor sets in these games
i mean this just looks really good
doesn't it this this armor set
i mean this is this just looks awesome
i'd love this
oh looks
yeah never mind
i don't know if i can agree with you on
that one man okay let's go kill uh
let's go kill reichard
so we can go
um
we gotta kill the noble don't
we we in the yeah we're in the prison
town okay
actually uh no i did that okay yeah yeah
yeah okay
we should go talk
to
raya first
before i go down there
is going well and quickly
might be the costco too especially since
dad won't be up until seven have fun
streaming okay cool
i might get a tv today chat
because my tv is uh
10 years old
what about the mountaintop quest you
have to do you don't technically have to
wait raya
alright smash your pass raya
you all haven't said that one yet
there she is
what up bryan you look great brave
tarnished
what is your business here
i'm afraid this is not a guest room
what's that this form upon your face
goodness
am i still a serpent
oh how dreadful
how dreadful indeed you guys are all
very horny aren't you stressed
i hope to be thanking you for treating
me as usual
despite this appearance
brave tarnished
this is my true form
my real name
is zarias zarias shift the deception
do understand
this duplicity is my own doing
lady tanith speaks no falsehoods she is
just hollow
just as it seems
lady tanith is my mother i am told i was
born in the grace of a glorious king
that my mother cherishes this form i
inhabit
i am proud of what i am
but people are as you should be
if they saw my true form they wouldn't
speak to me
and so i assume a guise when seeking new
recruits
but you are not like the rest
yeah i'm pretty cool my serpentine form
and the name zaryas
were secrets
known only to lady tanith and i she's
just so sweet the secrets with you as
well
please keep them safe from anyone else
she doesn't know who her parents are
it's a part of her questline we're we're
gonna do a request line my serpentine
form
okay secrets so now i gotta go rest and
then i gotta talk to lady tanith and
then
so you guys are saying you would smash
anything i think we already said that
earlier that you guys would quite
literally smash anything in the world of
elden ring how many times you completed
the game
uh i would say probably like six or
seven times if you follow this heroic
path i have 350 hours
yeah 350. a day too soon
soraya's form did you see her
the girl
raya
with her true face
yes
well
if she confided in you the name zarias
then perhaps it is not my place to speak
but
as her adoptive mother
i ask of you
please
be kind to her
look after young psarias
her true visage belies the purity of her
heart
honestly
i hardly deserve the sweet child oh
[Music]
please
be her true visage belies the purity of
her okay same thing all right
i command thee
for i am the lord of all that is golden
um
oh
it's you what'd she [ __ ] forget the
heck my mind never ceases to turn off
late
i platinum dark souls 2. i've never felt
so empty before
i saw something like you liked it so
much that now you'd or you just didn't
think it was worth it
it entered the room next to this one
and never came out i don't even think i
ever finished dark souls 2.
it took the form of a serpent
just like me
yes i did volcano manor i played it one
time
the lady tanis has kept from me
i realized that i shouldn't impose but
if you discover anything
would you please share
tell her the dark side of volcano manor
really
oh so there was a secret after all
oh my
lady tanith my own mother has deceived
me
was i not you guys like dark souls 2 by
the grace of a king
i know a lot of people who watch the
stream are
like elden rings their first game
dark souls 2 is not a bad game it's not
it's just my least favorite souls game
by the grace of a king
it's a it's a good game it really is
lady tanis was i not owned by the
i see she's realizing
wait no i can go ask her now
that i told her i think
i might have to rest first
please
i don't she said that
to you
i should have known something was wrong
the signs were clear enough
ellen rings your first yeah i know
that's a lot or um
yeah all the more reason a lot of people
are like that yeah that some things are
better left unknown
besides
no one should be blamed for their
heritage
think about it
we are resisting the ways of the earth
tree itself
what matters one's linny sakiro is an
incredible game
it's so [ __ ] good for what it is
zaryas has placed her trust in you
all the more reason i must tell you that
some things are better left unknown no
i've never played monster hunter world
one should be blamed for their heritage
okay
can you talk to her again
also doesn't patches like tana lady
tanis was i not
by the
did i not do all of her dialogue
i might be tripping bro
you think they'll announce dlc at summer
games pass i
i can guarantee that they're making dlc
i just don't know when they're gonna
release it
i don't know
if you follow this
cannot
okay
yeah
patches has a crush on her
hello again welcome to
what about my reward
sharper than you seem aren't you
i was just holding on to it for you you
know
there you go
the reward for hunting tragoth
all yours
magma whip candlestick
huge
stingy little try to find it
nothing else i can say
yeah i i would not think of any dlc
coming too soon because it's only been
three months guys
that's that's not that long
it's really not to make uh dlc
lady tanis was i know home but
okay i think we can move on now so let's
go out here
michela dragon more dlc
it's too long
elden ring
oh to come out with dlc
i know you guys know how [ __ ] hard it
would be to make dlc for this game
though how to how to properly add it
into the world
um
god it must be a grind bro
we don't have a poll
uh did you know after defeating
reichardt you can go back to the place
of that fight
uh yes i did yep
i can tell you as a souls-like
hardcore fan of monster hunter world
i
i don't know i don't know i'm scared to
i could play it on my own time i'm
obviously scared to play anything else
on like stream or make content for it
i wouldn't say i'm scared but i just
shouldn't you know
consist consistency is huge when it
comes to making content so i don't want
to mix anything up yet
yeah they um
they were
very surprised by elden ring's success
which i don't know why
i don't know why they wouldn't think
this game would pop off
like it did
ah hollow knight i've i've never tried
playing it i haven't tried playing it
man
what's up daniel
i'll give my monster hunter world a try
sure
miyazaki doesn't really like dlcs he
prefers having games finished on launch
that's not what dlcs are it's just extra
content it's not like it's not done
also he does there's plenty of there's
dlcs in every
every game
that he's made
so
i i don't think he dislikes dlc
also more money [ __ ] yeah
ow i'm gonna mess with you
didn't shakiro have dlc or no they just
had like a major update
so i guess not everything
bloodborne had dlc
dark souls had two dlcs
their dark souls 3 had two dlcs
um
yeah
a good amount of dlc
[Music]
i think after we beat the noble here we
may have enough
to
should have enough
to actually pick a weapon like enough
levels to pick a weapon we can make a
build off it and go from there
bloodborne two
two
oh yeah we we just have to wait there
will be dlc for this game it's just
gonna take a while
there's so many like they may
i'm sure they've decided what dlc's they
want to do
but
who knows what they'll do first because
there's so much they can go off of
what bill you going for i'm gonna let
chat decide we'll show like what we can
actually do and just have chat pick what
we do
what would the dlc be about pick
anything they could do it it's
it's all there
did i already drop this
and i just ran around for no reason okay
i didn't good
fire an ice sword
didn't it get uh nerfed
what would you like the dlc to be about
uh i'd like it to be about nicola
very much
mickela please
something with godwin as well that would
be great
but there's tons of stuff they could do
i think um i think what i would want the
most for them to do
is um
make
i want to go back in time
to when everything wasn't destroyed and
shitty like it is
before radon was crazy
you know
i want to go back in time
i hate fighting this guy
[Music]
i thought it was far enough away
nice belly pop there buddy
hang it
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
what is what
i've never seen that attack
i've never seen that attack ever
well maybe i'm tripping
[Music]
nice
that hurt
all right
there we go
oh badlands dlc
yeah dude
that'd be cool
see there's like a lot they could do
so much they could do
i want like if they make an update where
we can um
i want to be able to upgrade torrent and
put armor on torrent
that that could be a cool update that
they do like a really cool update
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
i see how much time i actually have left
because i'm spending the day with my
mother
which is to be amazing
and then it's my last or it's uh my
dad's last day of school he's an art
teacher
so he's going on the party bus tonight
we're going to meet him somewhere it's
going to be sick
i'm i'm so quick with the bots
don't even worry about the bots they're
trash
dolman
i don't know what that is
anyone that thinks
land of reeds
we need a soldier of godric dlc
that's what we need
all right before i think
we're going to pick what we want to do
like what build we want to go for
and then
we'll end for today and i'll be back on
tomorrow actually like i want to start
streaming a bit more than i do
so let's see
we have radon's sword that is a thing i
believe
yep we've got the great swords we're
gonna need 38 we'll have to add 38 to
strength but we could do that
we could
see if there's anything else we can get
um
don't have any other remembrances right
now but we could go get them
bolt of grand sax
morbius spilled
you guys letting that meme go bro
you're letting it rage aren't you
faith build
could do a faith build what what
weapon's good with faith
should we do a soldier of godric build
would actually be funny
see if i have like all their stuff
no
i could find it
this soldier of godric built
doesn't he have just a long sword
i like this idea though
no we killed him at the beginning where
can i get his clothes someone look that
up i'll look it up i'm the streamer i
should look it up you guys are here to
enjoy it
um
i want to wear his [ __ ] and just use his
long sword
yeah i mean soldier of god
as a patron i demand this build all
right but godric build
soldier of godric
just farm the soldiers in limb grave
yeah but there's a place we could just
buy them
that'd be way easier you know what i'm
saying okay godric soldier set
they're in stormgate um
drop all four pieces of the set and can
be easily found in the gate front
ruins they're just laying there oh
okay
here all right
that
and then you have to die to every boss
at least 50 times i do like this idea
though
i do
what sword does he use does he just use
a long sword like a long boy
what the
oh my bad
i think we can get a long sword from the
twin hus
we're doing a soldier of god rick build
i'm gonna need your clothes sir
cap vigor at base to make it more
realistic
i love that
come on open up
you're smart man smart man you are this
one
just as smart
now
where did my
did i just do
no
this man will let me get behind him
there we go
no i don't want to kill you you look
like my dog
it's in the caravan
there is a sword yeah is this the sword
he uses over here
lord soren's greatsword is this it
leave me alone
okay
i'm done [ __ ] about
i'll just use this one
is it in the other caravan
where is it oh there it is
[Music]
that's it right is this not what he uses
this looks sick
i'm pretty sure there's just a
morning star in here
nah that's our first playthrough
this is not new game plus or it's a
flail
all right what does this go so do we
want to do this
it's kind of [ __ ]
is it
anywhere
how do you already have the raging wolf
armor i mean we're just back here
where we were here for his armor where
is it i just reloaded all of them i'm so
stupid
all right where's it at
or is it just telling me i can find all
the sets here by killing all of them
is it bad this seems good
ow
stop hitting torrent
that's mean
holy [ __ ]
i can't sneeze
okay
[ __ ]
oh my god
i don't know this seems pretty cool
i need their armor though
oh we got the gauntlets boys
we got him
we got the gauntlets
oh
we went down here already didn't we
no
eat a silver foot oh yeah
true
okay
i got you
three to go right
is there another one over here you
you never know you never know
[Applause]
all right he didn't drop [ __ ]
oh another one
nothing
okay i'll use the foot
yeah i'm playing on pc
yeah you have to pause for five hours
after every hit
this could be unintentionally our
hardest challenge run
yo this foot not working super good
are we just that unlucky
that's something we got another pair of
gauntlets
that's sick
oh
we just got that i just picked wow
all right
that's something nope
bolts
bolts
we're trying to get the godric armor
godric soldier armor
oh my god guys delete tender delete
tinder oh my god delete tender
okay there we go gone see how quick that
is gone
dead
i'm picking up everything
oh come on mate
get out from behind your shields
a thin
potential
oh
because we're doing we're going to do a
soldier of godric build
that could be something
a war pic
not what we want
bruh
hold on i'm trying
okay
i love how high it launches them in the
air we ain't getting [ __ ] bro
the hell
this really the easiest way to do this
yeah you thought melania was a challenge
getting this armor is harder
a will smith build
is there a slap
ash of war
shut up
bruh
oh i have low arcane
that's true
give me your armor i could see it on you
nope
dude all those people we got
bolts
come on dude
is there really nowhere we can just buy
it
we got it we got the helmet
nice
okay we're looking for the armor
oh the foot ran out i don't think the
foot was doing too much
i should have been the voice actor for
this game for everything
it's too good let's go up here can we
get them from these guys up here
i feel like i'm playing world of
warcraft right now trying to get a drop
give me your clothes
now
damn it
give me your clothes
damn it
give me
your
damn it
take off your clothes
damn it
okay
this isn't going
yeah there is definitely a place we can
just buy it
death
you know troy baker voiced ronnie
no
dude watch i'm gonna i'm gonna go to
kali and he's to have it he's going to
be like yeah
here you go
he doesn't
he doesn't though
give me your clue
wait well
what the hell is that ew
okay goodbye where's another one we're
gonna figure this out
there's one right here
it's not like you're gonna use the foots
for anything other than armor probably
we haven't even been to the snow field
yet
really
i swear i've seen it where you can buy
it somewhere i swear but i could be
wrong
i'll check this one and then okay
you're right you're right you're right
we'll go back
this is kind of a fun meme build though
back to the feet
more feet
you with the horn
shut up
i'm gonna sneak
i'm a sneak
hey boy
you did we got another helmet
just not what we want
more feet
press one in chat if you love feet
you're a big fan of feet press one
that's what i thought that's what i
thought oh we can get the great shield
it's an option
ah we got bolts again
i'm seeing a lot of ones in the chat
i was too far away
i thought i'd stuff right through
come on
we got the greaves let's go
let's go
we just need the armor now
that's all we need
check one more time make sure i don't
already have it okay i don't
one more we got the greaves
nothing
come on
we got greaves again
if nothing can rest do it again do it
again
we go again
oh we should yeah yeah
yeah we just had to
we had to talk about feet
to get them to drop their boots
nope
nope
well if i were amber heard i'd just [ __ ]
in their bed and take their clothes
you
is this it chat
is this the one
god damn it
one more
[Music]
dang
it i'm gonna kill this deer out of anger
we go again
oh i don't have the foot thing anymore
though
rig
i didn't mean to fast i fast traveled
and you told me not to i'm stupid i'm
sorry
oh damn it we got gauntlets again
canceled on twitter that's fine
[Applause]
you know the only way what's the only
way that you can actually be canceled
chat what's the only way
that guy's [ __ ] blind
bolts
i'm sure you guys have all heard this
before what's the only way you can
actually be canceled
on the internet i suppose
side with elon
not if you acknowledge it that's kind of
a part of it
kinda sorta
amber heard has a ton of supporters i
wouldn't say she's cancelled
i got a smithing stone that's cool
don't use twitter that's a good one
just really not hurt this stuff i guess
there's technically two ways you could
be cancelled
one
is if you are removed from the platform
by
the platform so like let's say
you did something really bad and youtube
removed you
from your platform or twitter or
whatever right
actual removal
or
you cancel yourself
[Applause]
yeah trump like got canceled on twitter
basically
you can either be removed or you cancel
yourself you stop you stop posting
you stop doing what you were doing
before if you just completely stop
that's the only way you can get canceled
or
you're removed from the platform
i don't even think i can get what i want
from him
mom baby i want it
now we
is that a drop
no it's from the dog
didn't uh didn't youtube find nothing
wrong with quantum tv didn't they didn't
they put that on twitter
yeah they sided with him
or they just didn't research it all
which is probably the case
nothing there
i mean he's not canceled because he has
supporters he does
he's got there are people out there that
like quantum tv gets tens of thousands
of views on every video he makes
what the
all right
[Music]
dang it
i like these bats
we go again
god
you know actually i have a feeling it's
up here
are you jealous of brian's toy review of
course i am the kid plays with toys and
gets tens of millions of views
that'd be sick
the views are just there to cringe at
him yes but guess what he's still
getting paid
from that view
you
know
the man's still getting paid
you get paid by the view
dang it we got bolts again
[Applause]
bro
just drop the armor
oh my god
this is painful now you know why we're
not getting it because we want it
that's why we're not getting it
it's what we want
we're not getting it
i'm sending out oleg
he's so tall
[Music]
except exceptionally invati
well i'm glad you don't think i'm boring
that's good
i like to think i actually answer you
guys
i watch a lot of streams that don't even
talk to their chat which i do not
understand
what's the point
i don't have another foot
i think you play dark souls remastered
dark souls 3
yes
i want to do that whenever we beat the
completionist run of this game i would
like to go to
the other games as well
absolutely
i i did a community vote on it
looked like everyone wanted me to start
with bloodborne
which we could do
there it is
it's bolts
we got bolts boys
monolith get the drops
dude oleg is so op
oh yeah i'm
i am only on youtube
uh all the content i make youtube
i'm not a i'm not a fan of twitch i
don't like twitch
i think it's uh full of lazy content
you did
yeah i'm just not a fan
i'm not a fan of it as a creator
um i mean i streamed on twitch for four
years um
i mean i've talked about this before but
i've streamed on twitch for four years
and i got 20 000 followers i got
partnered on twitch i got i got all that
[ __ ] bro like
is you know i got all the as good as i
could get on twitch basically
and
i mean i guess like i got the highest
status of a partner
and
i had to to get to that point where to
get to 20 000 followers which is it's
really not even that much
it took me four years and constantly
plugging twitch on other platforms like
tick tock
i got
20 i got 20
million views on tick tock
plugging my twitch in every single one
of them and i got 20 000 followers from
that which is good
but for youtube i've had to do nothing
but make good content
nothing
and i've already
doubled what i did on twitch
so
i i think twitch is a horrible platform
for smaller creators to try and grow
their no matter how good your content is
on twitch
nobody [ __ ] sees it and that that's
just the truth of it
you you could make you could have the
best twitch stream but if no one knows
you're there no one will see it nobody
which is super frustrating
but i feel if you make good content on
youtube it'll it'll get pushed it may
take a while but it will get pushed
eventually
and then twitch i think is filled with a
lot of what i mean by lazy content
is um
i wouldn't say it's easier
i wouldn't use the word easy on
youtube it's really [ __ ] hard
you still have to make good
content which isn't easy
but
um
bro none of this is dropping
it's like uh
what
do you guys know what i mean by lazy
content right like
whenever i'm watching the biggest
streamers
on twitch they're all they're just
reacting to stuff they're watching
things they're
you know i and i love asthma gold by the
way i love him to death but he he
watched the amber heard stuff
and he had like 200 000 viewers just
watching
the johnny depp trial any and he
provides like great commentary for it
and everything
but
it's super [ __ ] low effort he doesn't
have to do anything but just watch it
and talk you know
and then he puts it on youtube and it
gets millions of views
um
i don't know i maybe lazy is not the
right word for it but i find it like
just low quality
[ __ ]
but that's the thing like some people
like that some people like low quality
stuff
and i would say most kids do
right like most kids like low quality
[Applause]
damn it i keep getting bolts dude
but yeah it's uh
and then you got all these chicks just
like sitting in asmr like doing asmrs
sitting in their [ __ ]
hot tub in their living room or whatever
i'm just like this this site sucks
and then and then people just started
[ __ ] gambling and those are the
biggest streams on there now and i'm
like yeah i'm out i'm over it
i got another smithing stone
which i can't blame those creators
for uh
for doing easy content and making
millions of dollars for it you know like
good for them
but
if you're
trying to grow your channel
by just streaming
you'll you'll never be found
you could have the like i said you could
have the best streams out there but it
won't
it won't matter
what do you think of mr beast he makes
the bet what some of the best content
i've ever seen
on this platform
super original
really fun to watch videos like they're
great
do i watch all of them nope
but they're good videos i can see why
they get that many views
come on just be it
damn it
we're never gonna get this are we
yep they'll just why
that's what i mean by lazy content it's
just
as easy as it gets for them
that but that's the thing like they get
views though so of course they're gonna
make
easy content right
you know why wouldn't why wouldn't they
if it gets them views and makes them a
lot of money
i did use the i used both of the foots
that i had
i can't even swing there we go
we are really going at godric's army
here
yeah i got frustrated with the platform
after
um i realized how many views i was
getting
um on other platforms dang it
and all with plugging twitch and it just
it's just
yeah i don't like twitch
that's all i gave it as hard of a try as
i could
we're streaming for four years
but i made the switch to youtube and
it's been so much better at least in my
opinion
thank you vanessa
is this it
another smithing stone
we've gotten two helmets
two gauntlets
and two smithing stones
but no chess piece
oh yeah not to mention the [ __ ] ads
on twitch right oh my god
didn't even get into that it's they're
so intrusive they're so annoying
whereas on youtube you can just skip
them after five seconds if you want to
like i don't even think of ads on
youtube
oh i'll take a smithing stone absolutely
hey i'll take another one look at that
no youtube is my main job right now we
got another helmet oh my god we got
another helmet
pain
yeah this is my job streaming and making
videos on youtube
absolutely
left the
i'm thinking of buying a house
i'm gonna go looking
uh later today
actually near you
i pay for youtube premium so i don't
have ads
uh i despise them seeing an outer
product makes me not want to ever buy
that product i completely agree
i think i think ads are totally
totally useless
like
how how often has you have you guys seen
a video or an ad for something
and you actually
bought that product
i'm playing on pc
i think when it comes to at least
youtube or twitch i've never once
clicked on an ad
ever
i'll buy something if i want to you know
not if i'm being marketed it another
smithing stone
dang it
come on baby
come on baby
dude another one
oh my god
but the spreadsheets
i watched some anime i wouldn't call
myself an avid viewer of anime but i
have seen
certain
certain shows
we got more bolts oh my god
yeah i've clip clicked the skip button
lol
doggy
okay
too when are you streaming uh whenever
we get this armor set i will probably
end stream
cause i do have to be somewhere later
and i want to go hit golf balls too
that'd be fun
that sounds like a good time
is that all of them out here yup man bro
it's 12 30 here
i started around nine
uh i feel like i get the surcoat
randomly all the time
you know what hold on
uh i'll be on tomorrow at some point
probably tomorrow morning again maybe a
little later than today
hold on i'm looking something up
so it's the tree and b circle
[Music]
they drop from these guys that's it
you you can't you have to get them
dropped by these guys that's crazy
all right let's do it
i i do want to start streaming more i've
been having such a good time streaming
got another straight sword
and i think um
i think youtube's just getting started
with streaming on this platform i really
do
oh
we got the greaves again
no
this is just for a meme build bro but i
want it
whoops
let me hit him thank you
no
we got the gauntlets
come on
nostalgia stream
dang it
pick
but you know like obviously the stuff
that i get the most views from is from
the lore videos
so i want to work on those as well we
got the
gun
obviously we get the most views from
lore videos so i want to keep making
those
and it takes time to make those man it
really does
yeah we're just making what we're doing
right now is the evolution and lore of
the soldier of godric like we are that
person and this is what it took to get
there
just farming his own men
how many how many graves you gonna give
me dog how many grieves are you gonna
give me
holy panoli
now i'm hungry
i don't even know what a panoli is it's
a cannoli
you you're the one you're glistening
you're the one
please
i'm gonna do a ritual
i'm gonna do a curtsy
i'm a bow
yes
this is the armor
this is our set
please
um
come with me
come with me
all right
three
[Music]
two
one
hate squirrels
god i'm killing these guys
what it's gonna drop from this guy right
here one one try
nevermind
mommy
i'm leaving
all right come on i feel i feel like i'm
playing an mmo right now
for real
trying to get a drop
god
we got gauntlets again
where is this circo man come on
smithing stone
i feel like i'm getting more drops on
torrent
will you be leveling up the sword yes of
course
there it is baby
we got it
oh my god it only took 45 minutes
there it is
baby oh so random
the build
yes
the soldier of godric comes for you
soldier of god named rick
i'll even go this far
i'm going on watch watch this
where did he flee young
means
that's as far as it can go
soldier of god
i can't type it all out man i'm just
calling him rick
rick
yeah i spelled soldier wrong i don't
care
we're just going with the brick
all right
i would
so
what levels with our sword
strength and decks
let's get it
dude these [ __ ] bots
now
bear this sweeting into life anew
all right
strength
40
decks
40
vigor
oh [ __ ] okay maybe we can't do that yet
we'll go with 30 for now in each
go 35 bigger no 40 vigor
do we need that much we need endurance
let's do this
well we need straight the decks
it scales with strength in dexterity yes
we'll get some endurance in there as
well this is fine for now
i can't just have no vigor all right
i'll ask chat no we'll die to everything
man i can't do the lowest bigger
i guess that is a part of it isn't it
[ __ ] no
all right 12.
doing 20 of this
can i have
oh no
[ __ ] it man
the true build has started
soldier of
soldier of god
rick
is born
no vigor only strength and dexterity
puny tarnished
this is so stupid
look at our hb bar
all right let's go fight uh let's go
find our boy
let's go fight reichardt [ __ ] it man
just to just put it out there
can we even do this fight with this
little help
it looks so stupid
oh god
press one in chad if he would smash rick
i am not using only my sword on reichard
heck no
we'll die in the lava
we almost died to that
i need to heal
guys i don't even have the sword leveled
right now
which is what i should have done we have
plenty of smithing
stones let me just get there
one one one one one one one
serpent hunters for the maiden list
oh hi
what are you doing here
what up
nice
you should
okay
go for it
yeah
welcome home good for you
my dad's really really happy right now
because he just got back from his last
day of school
activate the shortcut
is that what i'm doing right now
i'm talking to my dad
he just got home
he's very happy
all right let me go level the sword you
guys
convinced me to do so much [ __ ]
some more into it
i can't even level oh my god all right
i'll need it i'll need it anyway
do you guys just want me to be tortured
is this what you want
we're not even gonna be able to
this will finish kill god
i can do better than this
it needs to slay a bloody guy i killed
the bot
oh
it's you
don't pay me any mind it's not important
naked just lay out your arms
okay
son of a [ __ ] okay
i can i can do this
should be a no leveling playthrough
i look kind of badass right now huh
these gauntlets look cool
i have a mod
they're just not here ever
no naked people
you already did the grace for the boss
but if you want
let's get the dagger talisman you should
activate the elevator it's there in the
temple
so oh yeah yeah yeah
that's fine we're already there
i why am i dumb why why am i stupid
how do they keep like what is happening
god
these bots smell bad
you smell bad but
okay
how many i need
for have no i no idea how many threes
yeah everybody report those bots by the
way that would help me out
that's what i'm doing and then hiding
them but they just keep making new
accounts because they're not real
all right that's as good as we can do
for now
let's see how much damage we actually do
to reichard
where even is it
we're just gonna get hit in the lava
like this is gonna be so dumb
i'm picking this up
we are we're not gonna be able to move
all right i'll do this
[ __ ] it
the soldier of god
rick is here
[Music]
we back it up [ __ ]
oh
get wrecked nerd
get him iglay
oleg
oleg dead
we have a better plan
why do i talk
all right i tried i i indulged in you
chat i did
this is gonna this is gonna be hard
with
the serpent hunter
i indulged in your shenanigans chat it's
over we're doing it
i can't believe i staggered them though
that might have been oleg and not me
i don't know
we have no health remember that
i just dodged inside of his mouth
stagger
he didn't stagger
he did not do that
he didn't he he didn't
he didn't stagger there like i thought
he would well rip all those runes
unfortunate i'm gonna pop this on as
well
don't i have a golden foot
i don't have any golden foots bro
mean free
i pretty much can't get hit or i die
yeah
oh now you stagger you stupid [ __ ]
[Music]
i don't like that
he smells good
yeah check the description yoda
oh
this boss is so cool
oh very well
the very
together
we will devour
[Music]
he sounds so cool
all right we got this come on
[Music]
that's bad
we don't want this
we gotta go
he can reach that bar
no we can devour
god together
he stretched
all the way across the map to grab me
there i didn't think he could reach that
far
oh my god that was insane
considering we die in one hit
now that we're doing the stupid build
on a 100 playthrough for some reason
i don't know what just happened
i thought he'd stagger
i don't think i had the stamina for the
second swing so it didn't do it
we got it though we got it this is fine
we're fine
this is fine
yeah i got impatient
all right
you know what okay okay this is gonna
take a while let's just come back to
this tomorrow i got i gotta leave soon
i can tell this is going to take a
minute i'm out of here bro
like i'm i'm out of the
[ __ ] vibes man but uh
we'll pick this up again tomorrow guys
like i gotta go
my dad just got home so
thank you all for being here you guys
are [ __ ] awesome
um
i'm having so much fun streaming
on youtube lately it's been great so
thank you all very much for the support
it's a great stream today
appreciate you being here uh i'll be
back
probably around the same time tomorrow
maybe a little bit later into the
morning or afternoon um just look be on
the lookout for that you can always set
a reminder
um
leave a like i don't know subscribe
whatever you guys want to do um
already working on the next lore video i
won't tell you what it is but um i'm
gonna start doing snapchat lore videos
uh which mean they're gonna be shorter
just some of them i'm still gonna make
longer lore videos as well on certain
subjects but
um i'm gonna start doing snapshots of
like uh
smaller
topics that i still think are very
interesting and that most maybe some
people don't know
so i'm gonna start doing that should
come out soon um but other than that you
all have a great rest of your day i'm
gonna go party with my dad
and uh i'll see you guys tomorrow all
right let me ban this [ __ ] bot one
more time all right and we'll be back
banning more bots tomorrow
all right peace out thank you all so
much
bye bye bye